noch vor zehn tagen lag mit corona im
krankenhaus jetzt badet er in der menge
der erste wahlkampfauftritt von donald
trump nach seiner krone erkrankung am
montag in florida und sofort geht er in
die offensive beiden unterstützer
verursachten chaos in den straßen wenn
er gewinnt wird es überall tumulte geben
aber er wird nicht gewinnen wenn er
gewinnen würde wäre er wohl der
schlechteste präsidentschaftskandidat
der geschichte und ich habe ihn am
schlafittchen ich habe ihn das
selbstbewusste auftreten trams täuscht
darüber hinweg dass seine wiederwahl auf
der kippe steht und die korona
erkrankung des präsidenten den vorsprung
seines politischen konkurrenten joe
biden noch verstärkt hat
in sachen wir ossis zu beobachten dass
es hier kaum sicherheitsvorkehrungen
gibt bezüglich des virus die meisten
menschen tragen keine masken der
präsident selbst hat ebenfalls keine
maske getragen als er aus dem flugzeug
ausgestiegen ist ja viele kritiker
könnten sagen das könnte ein neuer super
sprayer erwähnt hier sein und den
menschen hier stört das nicht wahrhaben
störe taugen die 4000 fans in stanford
halten ihrem idol demonstrativ die treue
ansteckungsgefahr hin oder her
das hier sind trump leute das hier ist
trump land sagt diese frau florida wird
trump wählen
ja ich war schon besorgt um seine
gesundheit jeder in seinem alter kann ja
komplikationen mit corona bekommen und
ich war einfach nur froh dass er keine
größeren probleme hatte durch diesen
chinesischen virus betont dieser mann
sich lieber an ihm dass er kein
karrierepolitiker ist und sagt was er
denkt meint diese frau klagt er macht
das nicht immer auf die feingeistige art
aber er ist ehrlich und hält was er
verspricht
trotz begeisterter fans donald trump
muss sich anstrengen um joe biden noch
einzuholen
laut meinungsumfragen konnte sein
konkurrent in wisconsin pennsylvania
weiter zu gewinnen und auch das senioren
paradies florida steht auf der kippe
trotz oder gerade wegen trumps lässige
haltung in sachen corona
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren